small price to pay for all the will give
from my love
I said I'm a Lincoln what a metal a
better care two brothers and sisters and
dear friends before I start when the
phrase allah subhanho wa taala the most
merciful the most trust or praised his
glory and gratitude belong to him for
the work that we do we're in the house
again an environment where we have a
nice metal discussion a khandhas cushon
this is mainly dedicated for our
youngsters or the elders who have who
are young at heart who are watching this
is relish Allah you are welcome to this
house inshallah we will be discussing
well both the hosts this doesn't belong
to this you know and where's the coffee
[Laughter]
anyway anyway so cutting the job who
shot to a side yesterday actually a
Messenger Muhammad at a big midnight I
was coming I just came across this video
funnily enough I saw a picture of this
person and it looked very very familiar
to a prophet that we know in the park
and it said why I converted to
Christianity and left this time and I
was all like oh no this brother here
that was going on and he probably looks
like come on till I click the video and
I realized that's not the brother though
this is a person who's in America who
claims that he has left the fold of
Islam for Christianity yeah so we're
gonna be who's gonna watch it react to
it and see what we can derive from this
because I feel it all benefits from this
year okay are you ready yeah okay well
that's really let's call each other okay
guys so the video starts a little bit
research on this guy yeah so now as you
know a lot of people lie and this new
trend Obama next Muslim kinda thing
going on yet so I asked this guy yeah
assonance I said 6 players just to see
if he knows here so I came with a 5 so
as you can see here Roger
dawn noon and then ask him about killing
six people in mind when she didn't know
which is a odd I asked if I can call him
scopolamine he said I'm good dude I'm
ready to entertain the question of
skeptic no problem so I shortened
interesting ok here we go he's put this
really nice and high damage it was very
fast away he replied as well so I've
always maybe on his prayers he takes I'm
very serious when I was a Muslim so I
went to Google and tied
praise of Islam in English and guess
what
check this out guys so as you can see
Roger of the dawn before the noon after
the afternoon Margaret the sunset Asia
look at that even the common Air Marshal
on Okada now we can watch the video now
and also find out for ourselves if this
story adds up yo was good job thanks for
tuning in I'm Cyrus speaks and this is
my testimony as to how I converted from
Islam to Christianity so I know it's
crazy because a lot of people that
follow me
you know did not know that I used to be
a Muslim actually many of y'all have
been friends with me for years even did
not know that I converted it to
Christianity so I thought would be good
if I made a video giving my testimony
explaining how Jesus saved me from Islam
and also why I have decided to continue
in Christianity and in this way okay so
basically the first thing first is that
he claims that nobody knew this before
yeah so this is something that's coming
up with new year and funnily enough I
did a bit of research on him
and I went to his Instagram and I follow
this I suppose from 2014
68 why I'm not trying I'm not trying to
judge what there's there's this thing
that event evangelical Christians use
this is actually talk to them and I will
play a little clip of a well-known stem
ofup christian speaker who's J Smith oh
he actually said this that he they were
taught to pretend that they were Muslims
the new go to like an African country
and this has happened with some YouTube
or pretending to be a Muslim and this is
a part of that curriculum you could say
that they have to go inside the
community no learn and pretend that they
left the fold of Islam now what's funny
what this chap is that basically with
like you know what's funny what this is
because I checked his Instagram in 2014
is a hardcore Christian like his is he's
in the front line 2015 he's still goin
hard
16 17 18 he's just full on this he's
doing these concerts and things so what
came to my mind was at what part did you
become a Muslim mm oh brother
[Laughter]
so this is what as a young boy in
elementary school I took it upon myself
to start to learn and research as much
as I could about other religions I was
very interesting very curious being
absent of faith I decided to start
reading these different books and
reading these different books from
Judaism to atheism Christianity Islam
that list goes on and on and on I ended
up coming upon Islam and to me Islam
made sense it made sense to me because
ultimately islam teaches that you can
get to heaven based off of your good
works and good deed islam says you have
to do or as Christianity says Christ has
done that sure there's some degree of
truth and obviously there's two things
you have to understand the Quran says
will feel jealous always to Mojave
malcontent Allah muhammadun now this is
the Jannah that you used to do you
inherited because of what you did yeah
but at the same time we do believe that
the Prophet Muhammad SAW so himself said
they're actually gender is obtained
through the mercy of Allah Samaritan
so whereas here we do believe that
actions have a big part to play in
reaching Jenna we ultimately say that
it's from the mercy of Allah what's
interesting in Christianity they have
something called solar feed a solar free
day is the idea that so long as you
believe and by the way this is this is
exclusive to Protestantism yea so la
Vida is the idea that so long as you
believe that Christ has died for your
sins then almost you could say that this
was required yeah so it's your belief
that's required and in Islam we had a
group very similar to this called the
merger okay who actually said that the
belief was the the most important thing
and every all the actions are not
actually important whatsoever so there
was some degree of truth in that but
generally speaking Muslims who believe
in individual responsibility to
reconsider because there is a hadith a
the prophet sallallaahu said let me said
that a man will come on the day of
judgment and who Allah he would say to
Allah all I want to enter paradise with
my good deeds
a lot takes if I'm mistaken his eye and
weighed on the scales and his good deeds
and it's just a given to a message that
basically you cannot do good these that
you do it's not even you cannot even
equate to that I the blessing of the eye
that you can see with so at this moment
the man said look o Allah intermedia
partners with your mercy
so to reconcile that just because a las
marias not mean we do not put actions
forward to work yeah and this is a
criticism of Christianity in a sense
because the Christianity says that Adam
came yeah as a result of his sin you
have original sin yes and then Jesus
came and now he got rid of that sin so a
human being becomes yeah devoid of
individual responsibility because it's
almost as if one person gives him a sin
another person takes him it takes us in
a way all he has to do is believe in an
other story
exactly and that's the reason why sadly
today for example you have some
questions or a lot of Christians who go
down the route of doing certain things
that are wrong and they say look Jesus
died for my sins and one of the things
that we use in this time just to move
forward before just move forward is that
in Islam we do not believe we believe
Allah is the most merciful is the most
loving and just so we believe that mercy
and love if we understand what that
means that means that Allah tells us
that all son of Adam the prophet has
told us that Allah said if your sins
reached the heavens in the skies I will
forgive you as long as you do not
worship partners with me so Allah saying
Who am I require from the sinner is for
him to repent the college that he has a
Lord that's all forgiven and turned to
me
however in Christianity what is required
a lot of Christian cities a blood
sacrifice is required so what we see is
that if it got is really because they
talked about God's glory and I see
everybody and there's not a mercy we
need to understand that if God's really
love and mercy he might use the innocent
person to Daesan son to be blocks not
only that sacrifice blood they say we
need blood and we're like whoa God can
forgive moving forward on our behalf so
to me Islam made sense Islam says you
are not born into sin it says you'll
become a sinner I was living with my
mother and my stepfather it caused so
much friction in the household because
they were Christians and I disagreed
with Christianity it caused a lot of
conflict and I actually moved out to
live with my elder sister and her
husband and they were Muslims so ok so
this is something similar to what I
personally went from this world when I
came to Islam my dad had a big pond with
it but I had to leave and leave you know
a little brother told me so I related
with whatever is come from if this
really happened fast-forward a few years
later I'm living with my sister and her
husband and I'm in school and literally
it is the last day of school this school
was out and I ended up getting I ended
up getting into a fight I actually got
jumped after I got jumped I went home to
call some friends of mine my older
sister she saw me calling my homies and
she knew it was about to be some drama
so she's telling me you ain't bout to
bring no drama in my house anybody had
no hood dudes at my house trying to make
stuff pop off literally while we're
arguing and not comes at the door
we open the door and what do you know
it's this there's white Christian dude
at the DOE and and I say that because at
the time I was really dealing with
racism as well so my sister decides to
invite him and I don't know why she's a
Muslim I'm a Muslim we don't like
Christians whatever but she invites a
man yo or the second day he says she's a
Muslim that's the stuff I'm a Muslim and
we don't like Christians just are we
taught like to have hatred maybe it's
just in his experience I don't think
he's made the claim that he's tall he
was told up front okay
because he was said he was dealing with
racists okay some people that might
watch that might think that we as
Muslims just to clarify do we do we know
where we're - where - were told to
coexist with as it says in chapter 60
plus 8 as you know it and many possible
like yeah and in the Quran it says later
so we're not all alike Christians in the
Jews okay so we are not totally so we
don't know worry about that funny person
he said himself is he's gone through
some experiences yeah so he's telling us
how he and some of his church members
have decided since it is now the last
day of school and now technically a
summer that he and his staff went by
some of the youth in our neighborhood
and closeby neighborhoods over on to his
house my sister pressured me to go
because she said you are not about to be
getting this as some drama you need to
go somewhere where
some positivity you get kicked out you
go to your sister's house you sit at the
Muslim the door knocks you got into a
fight the door knocks a group of
Christian pastors come and your sister
says and they inviting you to go to
maybe a church wherever and your sister
says okay I need you need to go to
somewhere positivity go to the church
I'm just saying as a Muslim it's
conceivable or income inconceivable now
for cuz he'll take his word for [ __ ] cuz
the high school not that anything might
take you to a place come on
anyways argument's sake yeah maybe's
consumer so I'm at this guy's house and
I'm looking around it's like all these
Christians I have never been around this
many young Christians before my life
especially of different ethnicities
races you know just you know song and so
forth and they chillin we eatin food we
chopping it up we laughing and almost
out of nowhere a couple of hours goes by
and then this dude is just like hey
y'all we're gonna go ahead and turn
somewhere she's music going to start
worshiping the Lord I'm like bro what
worship who like I'm wow man see this
one I can't fool with y'all Church food
y'all Christians y'all always want to
worship and talk about Jesus it's like
I'm trying to have some good food I'm
trying to have some good time it was a
couple girls up in there I was I was
checking him out I was checking him out
so the crazy part come on man I'm sorry
you might think I'm big nitpicking yet
but as I'm listening checking out girls
yeah well he might have been doing it
just has been a sin no problem you know
what what can I get him a excuse to bar
about him saying we're gonna start
worshipping was that he turned on some
music it was like some weird hippie
music I mean it was contemporary
Christian music we're like an acoustic
guitar but I never heard that the only
gospel music I had ever heard was like
that gospel music so I'm thinking about
what is this weird hippie we love you
Jesus you know just you know weird was
not my man what is this is going on what
was really crazy to me though was that
all of the people in there all of the
kids the young adults literally began
somewhere
Jesus intimately personally like they
knew him personally like some will be
dancing someone we're singing the song
somewhere down on their knees crying
some were sitting down like literally
everyone was just worshiping and talking
to Jesus privately and I never seen that
before so you know like whatever you
know I'm trying to face towards Mecca
because you know Islam we're supposed to
face towards come on bro I'm not buying
it no I'm not buying it now you're in a
room people are starting to worship
Christian Jesus no problem that's their
faith they can do it and I say I as a
Muslim at that moment face towards Mecca
you faced was make up to pray you don't
just say okay people are doing this what
will choice make up okay I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna okay I'm just gonna stand
it doesn't add up I'm sorry for now you
didn't give me the Grove excuse and I've
took it on board yeah but someone's
doing something and then all of a sudden
I go as a Muslim we have never been
taught okay if you're in a crowd that
something happens turn towards Mecca the
most were told it leave the environment
and go away it doesn't make sense to me
I'm being honest thangka when you pray
how about ten minutes went went by and
the presence of God filled this man's
living room and I'm not usually a person
that talks about like feeling type stuff
or spiritual stuff in their way but
there is no other way to explain or
describe it than the presence of God
literally one thing I mean with critical
here
he said the presence of God came into
the room what do you define as the
presence of God and how do you notice
the presence of God because how do you
concern because this is an argument a
lot of people use it's the subjective
experience of okay what makes you
believe your faith is true it changed my
life
well okay as a Muslim concern you know
what I came to Islam and it dramatically
changed my life a Buddhist a Satan
worshiper a Christian a Jew and a
seekers come and say you know what my
life was changed it's not an argument
let alone to perceive and say that the
God what he said God's presence how do
you know it was God's presence and not
for example something else okay okay I
see well dad to then say it's fine to
have like you said subjective variance
which is religious and as you correctly
said I think that's actually very
important part of religion as well oh
you had that as well yeah when people go
to Mecca and they go - hi Jeff it's very
powerful
when I went to the cabin I saw the cover
for the first time yeah it was something
you know you're profound I went to Umrah
and [ __ ] and it's something for me
which was you know
self-revealing if you like what I don't
think this is this is the beautiful
thing about Islam it combines between
the spiritual aspect and the rational
and that's what I love about it right so
if if there is a spiritual if there's
something very spiritual about Islam
wise it's on a foundation which is very
shaky yeah or irrational yeah then it's
like building castles on sand or on thin
air even yes you can't build castles on
thin air you have to have very firm and
solid foundation and this is the
beautiful thing about them because its
premise until hate on the idea of one
God on the idea of one and only my lad
which of course is contrary to
Christianity which believes in 1 & 3 & 3
& 1 which is a self-contradiction it
goes against the law of contradiction it
actually goes against the law of
contradiction so no matter what
spiritual experience you're gonna have
thereafter yeah
you cannot fill the gaping hole which is
the intellectual base of Christianity
exactly because that's what's beautiful
like one thing that I personally don't
is not so I'm trying to figure out what
it is I'm thinking like nah man I'm
tripping you put something in the food
they don't spike the fool and I'm like
okay maybe that's not it okay maybe it's
my adrenaline since I got jumped earlier
I'm like maybe it's this weird hipster
music that they have planned so I'm
trying to figure out what it is but I
couldn't so eventually I got up in his
guest restaurant closed the door and
immediately started blaspheming and
cursing the name of Jesus okay
he's in a room he feels God's presence
if you feel God's presence I should have
a positive impact on you not a negative
one
he decides to go to the guest room and
in the guest room he says I started
cursing Jesus nation come on man I'm
being honest with you I'm not here to
mock anybody I'm not mocking this person
about what why they do that one second
number one are we allowed to curse other
people look let alone clothes other
deities which were not allowed a lot of
Tours we're not allowed not only that
you can be sinful because we know that
we are taught if i insult your mom I'm
cinnamon of course Jesus as a prophet
right
yes no I'm gonna come to that yeah if i
insult your mom and if you have college
it is from my mom
I get the sin when you cursing somebody
else's deity let alone a prophet of God
come on curses prophet good and they've
left the photo come on you're a Muslim
you went to another room you felt the
presence of God and you go to another
room and start cursing your own property
this guy he seems to have either to be
to be fair I'm gonna I've been trying to
refer to him as you have been yeah and
I've been true critical yeah it doesn't
work one about this no I know adding up
maybe what he was upon was no Islam
maybe he didn't actually because if he
feels like cursing because it seems like
he's saying is that because he was in
that environment yeah we're all kind of
charming Jesus his name to counter that
he went inside cursing Jesus you don't
do that so his understanding of Islam
must have been at best dangerous no I
I'm very ignorant one right be so
peaceful I'm gonna beg to differ and say
I totally don't believe the story but
let's go it's nearly finished anyway
it's not the son of Allah and Allah does
not have children that Jesus is just a
prophet not even as great as the great
prophet Muhammad like I'm saying all of
these things that I have been studied
and raised up within Islam to believe
and about five minutes goes by and I
feel the presence of God you this man's
living room like just feel this man's
house and I'm on the floor crying
weeping it's under the presence of God
it's really interesting though like to
be fair to things I wanna no matter who
becomes Muslim and who leaves this land
yes because the thing is at the time of
the Prophet or people have became Muslim
and left yeah we're not denying the fact
that opposed to see happen exactly that
was a visual experience those things
happen right
Allah has has you know has a message for
those people just a tube we echo higher
and higher now well yet I one love you
I've ever hung low either when I leave
my food don't ever for those individuals
if they really did come out of Islam
well the hot Carl Akeley massive cover
bodies lemme move
if they said that they're carrying
medical and they came out with Lam if
they come back Allah will he will
forgive them yeah and if they turn away
he will punish them in this world and
the hereafter apostasy happens yes and
Allah has certain methodology with those
individuals their apostate as into Toba
however what I wanted to say is that
number one it doesn't mean anything if
people come into Islam well come out of
Islam whether Islam is the fastest
growing religion which it is pew says
that by the way six million people come
become Muslim every single year six
million that's way more than
Christianity in terms of conversion only
conversion only that's how they
estimated so in terms of conversion
Islam is doing the best in terms of
conversion if you don't kind of take ATS
into consideration but that doesn't mean
anything whether it's people are
converting to Islam whether people
whether there's one Muslim or a billion
Muslims or three most whatever maybe it
doesn't matter yeah
yeah or people are leaving Islam or
people are coming into Islam the truth
to the truth and so what I find really
striking about conversion stories which
Christians that have become Muslim is
that it's usually quite rational they
talk about the Trinity and how they've
come to realize that in the Trinity the
Father the Son the Holy Spirit if you if
you ask a Christian is the father God
you'll say yes the son gone yes the Holy
Spirit yes they're all one God yeah that
is a con that's a contradiction most
Christians can't fire them and live with
very rational well that's how they
become Muslim you're totally right you
hit the nail on the head my issue is not
that my problem is this yes dad it's sad
because right now what we see is because
Islam is growing missionary tactics are
going down the route of lying and
deceiving but they were something when
they were not that's the problem that I
had if I heard this and the guy said you
know what I genuinely didn't disturb
that this what happened I would
understand but the way is going about
and there's simple things in the
standard you don't do that he's doing
and say nothing it doesn't add up to me
person that's what I'm saying
I have no problem Allah doesn't need
anybody if everybody started apostate it
doesn't mean nothing but and this may
not even know what's going on
I get up I look in the mirror I'm wiping
the tears and I'm like god I'm not even
a Christian I'm a Muslim I was like I
don't even believe your Bible is true
because islam teaches that the Bible is
only partially true and for the first
time ever I heard God's voice and God
spoke to me he said don't worry about
changing don't worry about transforming
read my word and allow my word and my
love to transform you after that I
didn't immediately just get saved and
everything was was rose petals it was a
huge tug of war between both the face
within my heart no Christian saying this
I'm just really curious just a bit and I
don't mean I genuinely because I know a
lot Christian people no friends that are
Christian we know in the park in order
it them genuinely how do you know that
the person or whatever is talking to you
is God but not Satan but how do you know
how do you come to this conclusion of
them what I heard is from God I always
I've always been curious it's for an
evidence to be an evidence and you'll be
somewhat verify for someone verify yes
you know as God I have is God would be
third person innocence we've all got to
see in an experiment with what you're
talking about if his first person it can
be good for you yes but you can't use
anything in my heart because I wanted to
honor God but I wanted to make sure that
I was doing it the right way but those
people lovingly walked with me and do
them walking with me do them showing me
through the text into the scriptures and
do their love I was able to realize that
Jesus is the Son of God He is God he is
more than just a prophet so man that is
the story as to how I got sick so that's
it man that's what it was and guys
brother and sister the reason I wanted
to you know do this is because it's
something that we can learn from and
understand that you know it personally
didn't adopt them no Outsiders also like
wow this is really interesting social
experiment one can do it themselves
yeah it's watch three videos like these
people converting out of Islam yeah and
then watch the videos people coming into
Islam and kind of compare yeah things
that people are saying because usually
you'll find that most of the things are
being said here in this video
particularly either emotional or highly
subjective exactly this is exactly
that's why it's time we don't believe in
blind faith we believe that you are less
what I said use your brain
use it pond up on my creation don't just
totally blind faith and that's what it
is this is how I felt because the
Christian the Satan worship was Satan
worship but you can say it Satan I was I
start well she was Satan my life has
been better it's been amazing guys
that's about it from us from the house
it's been a little a very not Velo a
very mellow chilling experiment that we
did inshallah inshallah if you guys have
benefited share with your friends and
family till next time take care
Romilly come over here